make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and i
feel like it'd be a cool idea to explain
chaos magic
in marvel comics especially because of
the one division tv show the nature of
wanda a lot of people probably have
questions about chaos magic whether or
not it applies to the events of
wandavision
and so what i want to do here is is
break this down in a pretty easy to
understand way and this video is not
going to be super lengthy because the
nature of chaos magic in and of itself
is not overly complex but there is a
little bit of history that we have to do
here
and this is going to tie partly into our
discussion on the darkhold explain so if
you guys haven't seen that video
make sure you guys check that video out
so you guys will have a more full
understanding of of that context as well
as what we're talking about here in this
video
so the idea of chaos magic in marvel
comics is something that originates with
a guy by the name of catholic
so if you go back to thor annual number
10 which was a story called in the
clutches of the god eater which was
written by mark gruenwald back in 1982
we kind of get this explanation of how
things used to exist on earth that's
somewhere along the line prior to the
existence of human beings
that what you had was basically the
demiurge and the demiurge was the
sentience of earth's biosphere basically
all the ecosystems on earth so almost
even to a degree like earth itself
but demiurge ended up spawning a whole
ton of different offspring right one of
these was a being by the name of gaia
but there were also a whole ton of other
things right cathone different people
like that
now all these elder gods were
exceedingly powerful in their own right
but cathone was especially powerful and
the reason why is because what he
started doing was actually traveling
throughout the universe and learning to
understand
magical energy and ultimately became the
most powerful of all the elder gods that
existed on earth and then ultimately
became a practicer of what was called
black magic or evil magic
and so what he did is he almost kind of
created his own magical energy
in the form of chaos magic now
ultimately he alongside pretty much all
the other elder gods ended up descending
into madness and evil right they just
became twisted screwed up versions of
themselves
and so gaia was one of the only few who
didn't fall prey to that change and so
what she did is she gave birth to a
being by the name of a tomb
known as the god eater and what a tomb
did is he basically
became the demi gorge he killed all the
elder gods
at least those who didn't die escape to
different dimensions which is what
cathode did he took off to different
to a different dimension and then
demogorged merged with the sun which is
kind of weird
the important thing to understand here
is that before cathode
left earth a couple things happened the
first is that he took
all of his knowledge of his dark magics
and he wrote them down
on flesh now this is where the dark hold
comes in because after that was done
about 30 000 years before the current
day
morgan le faye took all this this
magical knowledge from these pieces of
flesh that cathode had used
and then in turn put them all in a book
form and that's where the dark hold
comes from now something that i do want
to point out is that more recently
this was changed by marvel comics with
dan slott and the mighty avengers issues
number 21 through 23. and the whole idea
behind that is it basically established
that catholic existed at the same time
that humans did and catholic used his
power on humans and humans were so
incredibly afraid of catholic that they
actually worshipped him however a small
sect of humans who had the ability to
practice magic
actually ended up casting a spell that
basically said there is no god of chaos
right there's no such thing as chaos
magic
and there is no god of chaos and in
doing that and basically
wiping away people's knowledge of the
god of chaos that in turn
got rid of of catholic and locked him
away to a different dimension
i don't really ascribe that one and most
people who like the character of
catholic scroll it witch they don't
either it's just kind of a story that
exists out there this
is it's one of those things that like we
as comic book fans just kind of choose
to ignore
but uh but nonetheless the important
thing to understand here with the nature
of chaos magic is that it's not really a
form of magic that is random or
arbitrary
so referencing our video on agatha
hartness explain which i imagine most
all of you who are watching this have
watched that that in marvel you have
different forms of magical energy you've
got ambient magical energy and then you
have individuals who use the magical
energy of others what agatha harkness
does is she uses
ambient magical energy what somebody
like cathone did was using
ambient magical energy now cathone had
pushed his powers to the extreme
and he had dabbled and messed with
spells that act of the harness would
never dream of doing right just because
of the fact that it's such dark magic
and it twists the soul right it screws a
person up
uh and that's why cathone is so much
more powerful than agatha because she
artificially limits
what it is that she wants to do and how
potent her spells can be
somebody like stephen strange uses the
magical energy of
other beings right so he borrows powers
from like sidorak and he borrows powers
from dormammu and he borrows powers
from catholic and different people like
that he uses their magical power in
order to achieve
certain spells that's why doctor strange
his powers can be
super super huge and he it could be
insane how powerful he is he can be a
universal even a multiversal threat
or he can be a guy who can barely hold
his own against someone like the
juggernaut it all just kind of depends
how much of that magical energy
individuals are going to allow him to
use right so if everybody out there that
has magical powers lend stephen strange
100 of their magical energy he'd become
god but if they limit it and they say
you can only use like five percent or
something like that then he becomes much
much weaker
and so with with the scarlet witch and
chaos magic and cathode
the idea was that there was a prophecy
written that somewhere along the line
a person would be born who would have
the ability to become what was called a
harbinger or a host for catholic in the
sense that he'd be able to
leave his realm possess that person and
be reborn in the earthly plane at which
point he would basically conquer
everything and when he was imprisoned in
mount wondergore by morgan le faye
eons and eons ago that when the scarlet
witch was born that he had touched the
scarlet witch and given her a fraction
of his power
and that's how the scarlet witch has
been able to manipulate chaos magic
that's how she's been able to do the
things that she was able to do
is because she's so astronomically
powerful because she's been touched by a
form of magic that was so astronomically
powerful
now from there it goes into her using
hex probability because she didn't fully
understand the power she possessed
she just knew that she could do things
and she manifested that in the only way
she knew how and so as time went on in
marvel comics her ability to use her
magic became more complex but she never
really understood that she was using the
magic of catholic and even during the
events of house of m when she was able
to push that magic to the most extreme
even after in the aftermath of that
stephen strange's argument was there is
no such thing as chaos magic it was only
when he was confronted with the absolute
truth that it does exist that he finally
had to admit okay i guess it really does
exist right and that was that was kind
of it
uh but for the most part cathode is one
of these guys where it's it's
it's crazy how powerful he is right it's
crazy how how capable this guy is
you know the the the nature of chaos
magic is such that it allows an
individual who wields it in its entirety
right to the full extent of its ability
to completely and totally do anything
they want to
up to and including rewriting all of
reality right there's no limit
to the power to what it is that they can
achieve and just based on what we saw
with the scarlet witch it actually
allows a person to become a multiversal
threat because when you're talking about
the ability to wield limitless power
that means limitless in its absolute
definition there is no limit there now
the issue you run
into in the case of the scarlet witch
and the only reason why you didn't see
this
in in house of m is because you know
brian michael bendis and marvel just
wanted to tell the story
is that if a person is able to
manipulate magic on the multiversal
level like that and they start wiping
out universes or empowering other people
in universes giving people roles and
things they're not supposed to have and
so on and so forth
creating imbalance the living tribunal
will step in like a living tribunal will
say
no you're violating the laws of the
multiverse uh you are not supposed to be
in this universe doing these things
therefore stop or i will destroy you and
scholar which would be obliterated by
the power of the living tribunal
it's not much of a contest there right
she would be she would just be totally
destroyed because i mean
you're talking about a guy who's charged
with the power of the one above all
right so it's
there's there's not much that she would
be able to do to hold him off uh so
of course again you didn't see that in
the house of him because marvel didn't
want to put him in there because marvel
just wanted to tell the story and they
wanted wanted a reason to just
remove 98 of the mutant population's
powers and that was it but that's the
nature of chaos magic right not a whole
lot to discuss here it's basically just
a
type of magic that exists out there that
allows its user to achieve virtually any
feed that they want to achieve
so long as they're able to fully
understand the magic that they're using
and use it in its most extreme degree
right a person like scarlet witch in her
early days when she was using hex
probability didn't fully understand the
magic that she was wielding and so
because of that
it basically means that she was limited
in how she could use it basically meant
that her ability to use chaos magic was
limited in scope but as she's become
more powerful over the years she's been
able to manipulate chaos magic even more
right so with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
guys are new here to comics explained
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop
a like and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you